we pretty much picked up on finding that
orinda at a point where she was treated
about two weeks back so even though the
snare was removed we saw that over about
a two and a half week period her
conditions started again to rapidly
decline so we find that orinda in a tree
we think that by darting her she'll run
down it's actually contrary to what
happens we daughter she passed out in
the tree somehow we managed to get the
vehicle under they she falls on a
mattress we managed to pull her off and
actually treat her and cob antelope to
actually feed on the bushmeat snaring to
catch animals using wire snares is one
of the biggest threats to wildlife
across africa especially in the savanna
and forest areas of animals walk into
these snares they get caught they can't
escape they can't feed themselves the
concat water and then they neva tably
die now what that does is it affects
carnival numbers things like lions
hyenas wild dogs because sometimes the
corner was themselves a court and then
also the actual prey numbers get
depressed so they decline those conifers
have to move a lot bigger distances and
what the whole system actually collapses
the Lions in Queen Elizabeth National
Park they actually have a culture of
tree climbing and that's an important
tourism and lion sort of flagship point
you know it brings in tourism
it's an emblem for lion conservation in
Africa and that's why this depletion of
prey in that area is particularly
alarming because it puts stress on lions
in terms of harmony lions that era can
actually support I am optimistic in a
lot of ways about lion conservation and
big hair conservation in general the
good thing with cats like house cats is
that they're very good at breeding and
if there's prey and if there's any
slither of protection in the form of a
fence or ranges on the ground cats come
back quickly but it's just about giving
them that chance of protection
[Music]